bonjour et bienvenue dans cet épisode
qui parlera encore très peu de moyen-âge
mais d'un sujet que j'aime et dont
j'avais envie de parler depuis longtemps
les gens tout nus
suite à cette blague hilarante d'aliénor
la preuve hésitent à engager un
naturiste spécialisé dans les blagues de
borges pour cet épisode
voici son histoire et elle plante il fut
immédiatement licencié
bref on va parler des naturalistes ces
scientifiques explorateurs voyageurs qui
révolutionne les sciences naturelles
entre le 17e et le 19e siècle
[Musique]
le terme de naturalistes apparaît en
europe en 1527 et désigne les
spécialistes d'histoire naturelle mais
aussi ceux qui sont chargés de récolter
les spécimens ou encore ceux qui les
vendaient et aussi ceux qui suivaient
leur instinct naturel un terme un peu
fourre-tout donc l'intérêt pour
l'histoire naturelle ne date pas du 16e
siècle
dès l'antiquité elle regroupe la
botanique la zoologie la géologie et
passionne des savants tels cas reste pas
tout l'ancien le premier haut et créé en
maths syrie au septième siècle avant
jésus-christ et marque le début de cette
passion pour les animaux sauvages qu'on
aime a collecté au frais ou chasser les
savants gréco-romain initie également
l'inventaire est la classification de la
faune et de la flore à mon époque les
savants arabes et occidentaux s'inspire
des traités antique mais ajoute aussi
des observations personnelles
il ajoute aussi beaucoup de théologie à
leurs travaux pour eux les animaux sont
l'expression de la perfection divine
mieux ils s'encouragent l'étude des
sciences parce que la création
permettrait de mieux comprendre le
créateur à l'époque moderne cette idée
prend le nom de théologie naturelle
certains savants s'extasie devant les
merveilles de la nature et en tire des
conclusions sur l'existence et la bonté
de dieu
dès le xvième siècle avec en plus le
courant humaniste qui parcourt l'europe
on s'émerveille devant les animaux les
végétaux les minéraux et l'exploration
de l'amérique et des ombres permet de
découvrir de nouvelles espèces que les
botanistes rêve de connaître de
classifier
[Musique]
l'un des objectifs des expéditions
transportant des naturalistes à partir
du xviie siècle et donc la science il
peut s'agir de découvrir la faune et la
flore d'une nouvelle région du monde de
rencontrer des peuples inconnu de
ramener en europe des spécimens de
plantes ou d'animaux ou encore de
réaliser des observations astronomiques
les voyages permettent aussi de
compléter les cartes
l'un de leur but premier est souvent de
découvrir de nouvelles terres de tracer
les codes des continents ou deal de
trouver de nouvelles routes maritimes
ensuite bien sûr les états ne
financerait pas de telles expéditions
sans une idée politique derrière ces
voyages permettent d'effectuer des
reconnaissances d'établir des liens
diplomatiques ou commerciaux ou encore
de prendre possession de territoires
considérés comme vierge et de les
colonisés c'est le cas de l'australie
par exemple tous les britanniques
s'installe à partir de 1788 malgré la
présence des aborigènes l'exploration
scientifique permet aussi tout comme la
colonisation de faire rayonner la
puissance des états de constituer les
collections les plus larges possibles de
spécimens biologique ou minéraux la
croissance démographique et économique
de l'europe xviiie siècle contribuer à
encourager les recherches en sciences
naturelles puisque a aussi un but
économique derrière tout ça découvrir
les propriétés des végétaux permet de
les appliquer à l'agronomie à
l'industrie ou à la médecine dans la
botanique reste une science annexes
jusqu'au 19ème siècle ainsi de très
nombreux naturally se sont aussi médecin
et cherche à développer les
connaissances sur les plantes exotiques
ou locales quand ils voyagent ils sont
aussi chargés d'évaluer les ressources
exploitables
c'est le cas de l'expédition de la vénus
par exemple dans les années 1830 qui
doit évaluer l'intérêt de la chasse à la
baleine dans le pacifique peut pas
chasser les baleines pour les savants
les voyages sont l'occasion de valider
des théories de faire de nouvelles
découvertes et aussi de se faire un nom
des récits de voyages sont de grands
succès littéraires au xviiie siècle à la
fin de ce siècle malgré le bilan
scientifique positive des voyages
certains se posent la question de leur
utilité du fonds passe sa vie dans son
cabinet et ne travaillent qu'à partir de
ces livres des collections qu'ils
acquièrent toutefois les voyages sont
nécessaires pour enrichir les
collections et permettent de produire
récits de voyage et observations de
terrain que de simple collector de
spécimens ne pourrait pas réaliser avec
autant précision voyager travail de
bureau sont donc complémentaires
d'autant que les voyages servent comme
on l'avait
l'intérêt scientifique mais aussi
politique et économique les expéditions
naturalistes sont souvent divisés en
deux temps jusqu'aux années 1770
elles sont plutôt le fait de voyageurs
philosophe issus des pensée humaniste
puis des lumières qui parcourt le globe
avec une perspective encyclopédique
connaître le monde
il s'agit souvent alors d' aventure
individuelle dans les années 1780 les
voyages deviennent plutôt des
expéditions collective visant plusieurs
objectifs aussi bien politique que
scientifique
les naturalistes sont alors chargés
d'une mission se transforme parfois en
simple collector et enquêteur au service
de leur administration d instruction de
voyages voit le jour et les pratiques
d'observation de collecte et de
conservation des spécimens sont
normalisées en france cette
transformation est initié par la
révolution française à partir de 1789
l'assemblée cherche à encadrer les
voyages scientifiques afin qu'ils
servent plus la nation que leur gloire
individuelle
la jeune république française encourage
aussi la connaissance du territoire
français
manière de se l'approprier avant de
partir explorer l'autre bout du monde
entre 1792 et 1802 et rédigé un voyage
dans les départements de la france en 14
volumes qui incite la population et les
scientifiques à s'intéresser à leur
propre pays
à partir de 1794 des savants accompagne
aussi des expéditions vers des
territoires occupés par la france afin
de superviser la confiscation d'objets
et parmi eux des collections naturaliste
bien sûr des entreprises collectives
existe avant 1780 comme on le verra
ensuite
et les expéditions individuel continue
par la suite les savants sont plus
encadrés par l'état et sont plus aux
yeux de quantifier de mesurer les choses
et les territoires mais ils restent pour
la plupart imprégné par les idées des
lumières
l'état encourage donc les voyages
scientifiques depuis longtemps entre
1600 à 1615 l'apothicaire jean moquer
voyage autour du monde pour le compte
dans l'es4 puis de louis xiii et dirigea
son retour le cabinet de singularité
créée par le roi au louvre louis xiii
est aussi le fondateur du jardin royal
des plantes médicinales en 1635 le
jardin d'un rien d'un simple lieu de
plaisance rassemble des plantes
exotiques etc surintendant encourage la
recherche et les expéditions en 1793 ce
jardin devient le muséum national
d'histoire naturelle
est ce parce que ce titre contient un
mot vêtements latin que vous me faites
lire
loïc 15 s'intéresse également en
sciences naturelles et à la médecine
il possède son propre cabinet
curiosité encourage l'extension du
jardin du roi par buffon est
l'initiateur de plusieurs expéditions
telle que celle de bougainville en 1766
qui transporte le naturaliste philibert
commerson l'expédition transportait
aussi la maîtresse de ce dernier
déguisée en homme jaime barret mais ça
on en a déjà parlé dans un gentes dames
bad as tu fais un peu et puis louis saez
s'intéresse à la géographie
il supervise les expéditions de
lapérouse qui fait malheureusement
naufrage comme son règne les grandes
académies fondée dans la deuxième moitié
du xviie siècle jouent un rôle
déterminant dans le financement et
l'organisation des inventaires
naturalistes l'académie des sciences est
fondée en 1666 six ans après la royal
society de londres
cette institution ainsi que d'autres
organismes comme la société royale de
médecine procède à de nombreuses
enquêtes géographique topographie
biologique botanique et géologiques en
france et à l'étranger
les académies des sciences rédige des
manuels d'instruction pour les
expéditions maritimes et sont chargés de
désigner les savants qui accompagneront
telle ou telle expédition
le muséum d'histoire naturelle rassemble
aussi une collection de plus en plus
importante puisque la plupart des
spécimens rapportés par les expéditions
françaises y atterrissent en angleterre
le british muséum acquiert lui aussi une
collection de plus en plus démesurée au
cours du xviiie et du 19e siècle
ces organismes publie des ouvrages
dédiés aux méthodes de collecte et de
conservation des différents spécimens en
bocaux en herbiers en son nom au 19e
siècle le nombre de sociétés savantes
explose les académies de province se
multiplient et les disciplines se
spécialise botanique
géologie zoologie ornithologie les
académies permettent aussi une
reconnaissance officielle des
disciplines scientifiques
même s'il faut attendre la fin du 19e
siècle pour qu'à un botaniste ou
naturaliste puisse espérer faire
carrière uniquement dans ce domaine
beaucoup sont aussi médecin ou
bénéficier d'une fortune familiale qui
les met à l'abri du besoin
les naturalistes du début de l'époque
moderne sont empreintes d'humanisme
comme perez qui est à la fois astronomes
géographe botaniste collectionneur il
acclimate des plantes exotiques dans
cette demeure découvre la nébuleuse
d'orion recalcule la longueur de la
méditerranée dessine une carte lunaire
avec des amis défend galilée lors de son
procès bref un gars à la vie bien
remplie pour les naturalistes de son
époque la science est un inventaire
adressé une somme de connaissances riche
et diverse à accumuler et à diffuser le
plus possible
aucune discipline ne se suffit à
elle-même tout se complète jusqu'au
19ème siècle les naturalistes sont pour
beaucoup des amateurs instruit notamment
quand il s'agit de l'étude d'animaux ou
de végétaux au xviiie siècle le grand
public se passionne pour la botanique et
de nombreux amateurs se lance donc dans
l'inventaire de la flore un papillon de
papillons tran papillon on trouve parmi
eux aussi bien des hommes que des femmes
qui collectent des spécimens constituent
des herbiers et publie même quelques
ouvrages l'enseignement érudits des
sciences naturelles restent réservés aux
étudiants mais de nombreux ouvrages à
destination du grand public sont publiés
dans la seconde moitié du xviiie siècle
signe de l'engouement pour cette
discipline le nombre d'ouvragés appelé
flore à cette époque est impressionnant
à côté des naturalistes professionnels
comme jussieu où buffon son patronné par
de grandes institutions ou des grands
personnages pour se consacrer à leurs
activités
les médecins naturaliste constitue une
troisième catégorie de personnes ce sont
des personnes issues de milieux moyens
aux modestes intéressé à la botanique
dans le cadre de leurs études et qui
continue de la pratique et en tant que
loisir ou dans le cadre d'un poste
universitaire aux cadets milk être admis
dans une société savante est une étape
particulièrement forte dans leur
carrière
une reconnaissance de leur travail parmi
ces sociétés savantes j'ai découvert au
cours de mes recherches l'existence de
la société des amis de l'éléphant fondé
en 1905 à paris et qui visait à limiter
la chasse à l'éléphant en afrique un bel
exemple de la lutte contre la
disparition des espèces menacées
même si les fondateurs de la société
considère surtout que l'éléphant
pourrait être domestique
en europe pour porter de lourdes charges
la société a une portée scientifique
mais surtout mondaine elle donne des
dîners principalement et disparaît en
1910 au début du 19e siècle
l'activité des naturalistes bat son
plein et on comprend qu'une accumulation
des connaissances du monde est compliqué
personne ne peut plus prétendre tout
connaître
il faut collaborer les naturalistes
publie des récits de voyage et des
mémoires scientifiques souvent rédigées
en parallèle et aux limites parfois
floue on trouve des notes scientifiques
au milieu des récits de voyage et
l'émotion ressentie face à un paysage au
milieu d'eux d'observation plus concrète
tous ces naturalistes amateurs médecins
professionnels correspondent à travers
l'europe et permettent la diffusion des
connaissances et le développement de la
recherche
les correspondances des naturalistes se
retrouve même parfois dans des
publications scientifiques si elles
contiennent des informations des
découvertes importantes
le papier est encore pas trop diffuser
certaines sont inscrits sur des supports
inattendu le naturaliste guitare
écrivait parfois sur des jeux de cartes
ou des programmes du théâtre avec leurs
lettres et s'échangent des échantillons
des herbiers des idées les herbiers
surtout constitue la base du travail des
naturalistes et font l'objet d'un
commerce florissant florissant verbier
les illustrations sont une autre
composante importante et sont l'apanage
d'artistes spécialisé dans la peinture
de fleurs des grandes expéditions des
18e et 19e siècles embarque toujours un
peintre dessinateur avec leurs équipes
scientifiques dont le travail est de
dessiner tous les spécimens découverts
durant le voyage en vue d'une
publication
ces illustrations permettent de
continuer le travail d'identification et
de classements des naturalistes lorsque
le spécimen n'est plus à ses frais elles
sont donc d'une grande précision
scientifique et ne sont dépassés qu'avec
le développement de la photographie au
xxème siècle jusque dans les années 1960
malgré tout le british muséum continue
de financer un service complet de
dessinateurs et de les embarquer dans
ses expéditions à cause du nombre
grandissant des espèces découvertes se
posent la question de leur
classification
il existe en effet un risque que des
inventaires zoologique et botanique se
superposent suivant chacun leur propre
logique ou donnant plusieurs noms à une
même plante au début du xviiie siècle
les botanistes répertorie plus de dix
mille espèces selon un classement
alphabétique largement
passé il est donc nécessaire de
normaliser la classification des espèces
et de la rendre universel durant
l'antiquité la classification dépendent
et de la manière dont les hommes voyez
les espèces végétales ou animales dans
son traité d'agronomie var on classe les
animaux selon leur type d'élevage et
leur utilité au début du 16e siècle
c'est alpinois gasner fond de la notion
d'espèce soit un groupe d'individus qui
se reproduit à l'identique leurs
croisements donne donc un hybride comme
les centaures ouais
les naturalistes du xviiie siècle
continue de se reposer sur cette notion
d'espèce mais doivent trouver comment
les organiser environ 25 systèmes de
classification différents sont proposés
dans la première moitié du xviiie siècle
pour les plantes tournefort propose un
système reposant sur la forme des
corolles des fleurs par exemple charline
et un naturaliste suédois font d'un
système dépendant du nombre et de la
disposition des organes sexuels des
plantes
il est ensuite abandonnée au profit de
la méthode naturelle qui regroupe les
espèces selon leur ressemblance
morphologiques elle est amélioré par
d'autres naturalistes comme jussieu où
cuvier qu'il adapte aux animaux l'ine
marque plus durablement les sciences par
sa nomenclature jusque là on nommait une
espèce par un nom suivi d'une série de
qualificatifs parfois longue comme le
bras
l'ine propose en 1753 une nomenclature
binominale en latin avec le nom du genre
et le nom de l'espèce homo sapiens par
exemple même si ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde et il la propose d'abord
pour les plantes puis l'élargît aux
animaux en 1758 elle est universellement
adopté grâce à cette nomenclature les
savants de tous les pays peuvent établir
un savoir commun et les générations
suivantes presque - de repartir de zéro
on peut dire que la gloire de la
botanique s'augmente surtout en ce temps
où de toute part des hommes habillés
l'aîné pour de tels mystère observe dans
les lieux où ils demeurent chaque plante
en particulier qu'ils les marques les
décrivent en donne les dessins et les
conserves entre des feuilles de papier
afin que par là ils augmentent les
monuments immortel à un arbre qui ne
périra jamais la réforme protestante
joue pour beaucoup dans la
réinterprétation de la classe des hommes
et des animaux jusqu'à la fin du moyen
âge la théologie naturelle veut que les
animaux soient sur terre pour être
dominé par les hommes et donc chacun une
signification symbolique ou morale qu'on
retrouve dans les vestiaires médiévaux
le lion pour le courage par exemple à
partir de la fin du moyen-âge cette
lecture allégorique commence à être re
ôtez la nature est davantage observé
d'un point de vue scientifique
la religion ne disparaît pas pour autant
et l'étude des sciences est encouragée
par l'église car elle permis de mieux
connaître l'oeuvre de dieu william drame
naturaliste et théologien publie ainsi
en 1689 l' ouvrage de théologie
naturelle
la démonstration de l'existence et des
attributs de dieu
la théologie naturelle connaît un grand
succès au xviie siècle bien qu'elle soit
maintenant obsolète
elle joue un grand rôle dans la genèse
du naturalisme qu'on connaît au 18e et
19e siècles elle questionne la relation
entre l'homme et la nature et ébauches
même une approche écologique en
s'intéressant aux biens de toutes les
espèces naturelles durant l'antiquité
les sciences naturelles commence à
soulever quelques questions auxquelles
les naturalistes des époques suivante
tente de répondre la durée des temps
géologiques par exemple fait débat et
oppose les partisans d'un temps long à
foncer par aristote et les partisans du
temps décrit dans la bible ce débat
entre aristotélicien et théologien est
rouvert au treizième siècle à l'époque
de l'émergence des universités les
fossiles surtout soulève beaucoup de
questions même si on pense jusqu'au
xviie siècle qu'ils sont issus de
génération spontanée au milieu des
rochers
le savant arabe avicenne 11e siècle
pense que les fossiles proviennent d'une
coagulation de l'eau qui pétrifie les
animaux marins qui s'y trouvent ce qui
est moins con même si la théorie de la
génération spontanée demeure léonard de
vinci les étudier également et pense que
les fossiles sont d'anciens coquillages
pétrifié par les sédiments
mais ces carnets sont passés peu diffusé
ce n'est qu'à la fin du xviie siècle qu
on se dit qu'ils sont peut-être des
organismes ayant vécu dans les temps
passés
mais alors ils sont aussi pris comme une
preuve de l'existence du déluge
l'ancienneté de ces fossiles fait aussi
débat moyen-âge déjà certains savants
sont partisans d'un temps lourd pour
l'âge de la terre c'est le cadavre au lc
d'albert legrand tous les deux partisans
de la théorie d'aristote l'évêque de
paris condamne cette théorie au xiiie
siècle au 14e siècle jean buridan un
recteur de l'université de paris pense
que l'univers est éternel et gouvernés
par les astres et il pense que la terre
est divisé en plusieurs cycles longs de
dizaines de millions d'années au xviie
siècle de nouvelles théories
apparaissent rené descartes pensent que
l'âge de l'univers n'a pas de limites et
que la terre est une ancienne étoile en
train de se refroidir
en même temps l'église continue de
condamner certaines idées comme celle de
galilée au xviiie siècle de plus en plus
d'auteurs pense que la terre est plus
vieille que ce candidat
bhl mais les calculs sont difficiles à
faire buffon table sur 80 mille ans mais
c'est encore trop long pour les
défenseurs de l'église et il renonce
donc à son hypothèse le géologue giraud
sous la vie également au xviiie siècle
calcul l'âge de la terre à partir de
l'érosion des sols mais est également
critiqué les naturalistes ce rallye
progressivement à l'idée d'un temps long
à partir du début du 19e siècle mais
sont alors divisés entre ceux qui
pensent qu'il s'agit d'une succession de
temps calme et les catastrophistes qui
pensent que ce sont des temps longs /
des catastrophes
l'analyse des sédiments de l'as allures
de l'eau de mer de la décomposition des
éléments radioactifs et tout ce qui
permettrait de calculer l'âge réel de la
terre reste de toute façon hors de leur
portée mais les progrès sont réels
s'agissant des espèces dont l'évolution
est la disparition de certaines d'entre
elles commencent à être admise dont
calmer avant ce xviiie siècle qu'une
seule espèce par genre a pris place sur
l'arche de noé et qu'elle a ensuite
évolué et engendrait toutes les espèces
actuelles de son genre en 1809 la marque
publie sa philosophie zoologique dans
laquelle est défini le transformisme et
explique que les animaux se modifie par
adaptation à leur milieu
il explique aussi que les habitudes des
espèces entraîne le développement ou la
régression de certains organes et que
cela ne peut se faire que sur un temps
long il intègre les fossiles à sa
théorie
considérant que les animaux perdus sont
les ancêtres des animaux du monde actuel
a coûté ces travaux d'autres
naturalistes fond de la paléontologie
stratigraphique qui met en parallèle la
superposition des terrains et la
superposition des phones et des fleurs
en 1831 charles darwin est un jeune
théologien de 22 ans qui embarquent à
bord du beagle en tant que naturaliste
le navire longe les côtes d'amérique du
sud entre rio et la terre de feu et
darwin passe beaucoup de temps à terre
durant les escales faisant des
incursions de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres et ramenant de nombreuses
observations et spécimens à bord son
passage aux galapagos et le plus
marquant et lui apporte des preuves de
la théorie de l'évolution qu'il devinait
déjà via des fossiles des variations
géologique de la terre aux galapagos il
observe des espèces qui n'existe nulle
part ailleurs et même sur certains lots
des formes endémique distincte des îlots
voisins
les pins sont surtout le marque photos
d'oiseaux concurrents les becs des
pinsons des galapagos avait évolué
jusqu'à être adapté à tous les types
d'alimentation possible sur l'île durant
les années 1850 le scientifique beit ce
fait une observation similaire on
la zone et où il découvre le mimétisme
bézian des papillons inoffensive copie
l'apparence de papillons toxiques pour
se protéger des prédateurs
de retour en angleterre darwin passe de
nombreuses années à étudier les données
collectées durant son voyage est publié
en 1859 l'origine des espèces dans
lequel il explique le principe de
l'adaptation des espèces par la
sélection naturelle apparus par hasard
dans l'enchaînement des générations il
publie par la suite la filiation de
l'homme dans lequel il explique que
l'homme et le singe ont un ancêtre
commun
darwin n'était pas apte et il se définit
lui-même comme des listes puis
agnostique à la fin de sa vie sa théorie
est largement adoptée par des
scientifiques à la fin du 19e siècle
même si certains pays pêche encore un
peu cela fait de lui un des moteurs de
la laïcité scientifiques comme je vous
le disais les expéditions naturalistes
comporte des naturalistes mais aussi des
dessinateurs ou illustrateurs et parfois
des personnes plus spécialisés comme des
géologues zoologue botaniste astronomes
et c'est jusqu'au 19ème siècle ces
voyages demeure un confortable et
précaires les maires sont inconnues les
instruments sont imprécis les maladies
et l'hostilité des populations
rencontrées sont courantes
les expéditions peuvent aussi rencontrer
des bouleversements politiques en 1791
un navire est envoyé à la recherche de
l'expédition lapérouse
il est dirigé par d'entrecasteaux alors
qu'elle est en mer l'expédition apprend
la fin de la monarchie
cela provoque des conflits au sein de
l'équipage les scientifiques s'affiche
plutôt républicains le chef de
l'expédition moeurs et les officiers
partisans du roi décide de se rendre aux
hollandais il n'existe d'ailleurs pas
que des expéditions maritimes
beaucoup d'états commandes des
expéditions terrestre comme la russie
qui par explorait la sibérie dans les
années 1770 ou la france qui on voit
plus de 150 états en egypte en 1798 dans
cette partie je vais donc vous présenter
certains de ses voyages voici leur
histoire en 1687 ambitionner un médecin
reconnu de londres à une époque où la
royal society vient tout juste d'être
fondées et où la rigueur scientifique
des récits de voyages laisse encore à
désirer
si l'on ne s'intéresse à plein de
domaines des sciences et est appelée aux
services du gouverneur de jamaïque ce
qui lui convient fort bien durant son
voyage et les quinze mois passés sur
place ils amassent une quantité
impressionnante d'observation d'animaux
des phénomènes naturels qu'elle amène
700 espèces de plantes en angleterre
ainsi que de nombreux
illustration il embarque aussi un iguane
un crocodile est un serpent mais
l'iguane sautent du bateau et se noie le
crocodile meurt à bord et le serpent
s'échapper et tué par un matelot pas de
bol en angleterre il redevient médecin
mais a grandi son cercle de
connaissances il publie l'histoire
naturelle de la jamaïque en deux volumes
et s'installe un cabinet de curiosités
riche de douze mille 500 espèces
végétales 6000 coquillages 9000
invertébrés 1500 poisson 1200 oiseaux et
plus de 3000 vertébrés des milliers de
fossiles de minéraux de roches de métaux
précieux et semi précieux trente-deux
mille pièces et médailles beaucoup
d'antiquités et 50 mille livres ont pas
sûr qu'ils aient tout sûr il est élu
président de la royal society à la suite
d'isaac newton elec toute sa collection
à la nation anglaise
à sa mort en janvier 1753 le british
museum et créé en juin de la même année
puisque la collection de sione en
constituer la base en 1768 l'angleterre
est une grande puissance maritime la
royal society décidé de lancer une
expédition visant deux buts principaux
l'observation du transit de vénus devant
le soleil depuis tahiti afin de calculer
la distance terre soleil et la
découverte du continent austral encore
hypothétique
à l'époque on pense qu'il existe un
continent austral équivalents à ceux de
l'hémisphère nord et regorgeant
d'espèces et de peuples nouveau l'idée
s'ils étaient découverts étaient 2 le
cartographier de ramener des spécimens
de prendre contact avec la population
locale
les manchots et d'en prendre possession
pour l'angleterre et saint georges
james cook qui revenait de cartographie
en terre-neuve est nommé capitaine de
l'un des heureux il transporte
l'astronome chars green et le botaniste
joseph beuys ainsi que deux dessinateurs
et un botaniste débutants cook est
précis et méthodique son expédition ne
déplore que cinq décès jusqu'à la
dernière année ce qui est rare pour
l'époque
pas de bol le secrétaire du botaniste
benz est l'un de ces peintres font
partie des victimes
c'est donc là parkinson le deuxième
peintre de se taper tout le boulot
pendant le voyage il prend donc
l'habitude de réaliser des croquis
partiellement colorier et de les
terminer plus tard lors d'une autre
expédition anglaise en 1801 le
dessinateur bauer annoot ses croquis
d'un code couleur et ne les termine
qu'une fois rentré à londres faute de
temps
parce que l'expédition à est riche en
découvertes cook observe le passage de
vénus cherche le continent austral un
moment son succès puis longe la nouvelle
zélande et cartographie la côte nord de
l'australie
les botanistes récolte au passage de
nombreuses plantes et parkinson réalise
plus de 400 croquis durant cette période
de plantes d'oiseaux de poissons et de
kangourou
malheureusement le navire fait escale à
jakarta sur le voyage du retour ce qui
entraîne la mort de 30 membres de
l'équipage dont astronomes et le
dessinateur parkinson néanmoins son
expédition est un succès et coup québec
c'est rentrer en angleterre plein de
gloire et de nouveaux spécimens inconnu
qui viennent compléter la collection du
british museum cook repart entre 1772 et
1775 avec deux navires cette fois pour
une deuxième expédition à la recherche
du continent austral sont botaniste et
cette fois forster accompagné de son
fils george qui réalise 361 croquis
durant le voyage surtout au cap où cook
fait étape d'expédition descend ensuite
vers le pôle sud à plusieurs reprises
mais la banquise l'empêchent de repérer
le continent antarctique coûte ne
s'approche au plus près qu'à 75 milles
de la terre puis continue son voyage
vers la nouvelle zélande tahiti l'île de
pâques les marquises la polynésie il
découvre les nouvelles hébrides et la
nouvelle calédonie puis rentrer en
angleterre en ayant encore perdu que
quatre hommes durant le voyage
trois récits de l'expédition sont
publiés par cooke georges poster et son
père
la dernière expédition dont je voulais
parler et celle de lewis et clark de
1804 1806 à l'époque les états unis sont
un jeune pays dirigé par thomas
jefferson qui passionné de nature et
s'intéresse surtout aux territoires au
delà du mississippi par son côté
naturaliste et par son côté président
d'un pays qui cherche à s'étendre
il envoie donc une expédition avec un
cahier des charges bien remplie
cartographier le territoire récolter des
spécimens prendre contact avec les
populations locales faire des relevés
astronomiques
bien sûr il ya un souci de commerce et
d'appropriation du territoire mais
l'expédition est avant tout scientifique
et les tribus amérindiennes sont
étudiées d'un point de vue
anthropologique
c'est aussi l'une des rares expédition
américaine à s'être déroulé sans
violence lewis et clark échangent des
connaissances avec les locaux se plier à
l'heure
it et cherche à apprendre leur langue
ils sont les premiers à faire des
descriptions détaillées de la diversité
culturelle des différentes tribus aussi
bien au niveau de leurs traditions que
de leur habitat de leurs vêtements de
leur organisation sociale
la division du travail surtout les
étonne parce que dans beaucoup de tribus
les femmes effectuent les mêmes tâches
que les hommes
cette étude anthropologique voulue par
jefferson s'explique si on la remet dans
le contexte de l'époque
en 1803 il ignorait que les natifs
allait pratiquement disparaître
il pensait plutôt que leur culture
allait être progressivement remplacé par
le mode de vie américain
il tient donc à collecter le plus
d'informations possibles avant ça par la
suite et même sous la présidence de
jefferson l'attitude envers les natifs
devient beaucoup plus violente et les
scientifiques ont donc pour mission de
récolter le plus d'informations
possibles et à leur piquer leurs objets
avant qu'il disparaisse en 1803 donc on
n'en est pas là lewis et clark crée des
liens de confiance avec les tribus
rencontrer dans un but commercial
principalement et son pour ça en
concurrence avec les britanniques bien
implanté dans la région les échanges
donc des armes et des objets avec les
natifs pour en faire de futurs
consommateurs des produits américains
il étudie énormément de la nature aussi
et renvoie à l'américaine philosophical
society des spécimens varié de plantes
de rapports de spécimens d'articles
amérindiens et ses six ans et politiques
sont entremêlées tout au long de
l'expédition la collecte d'informations
naturaliste vise à identifier les futurs
bien ex potable à découvrir des plantes
médicinales par exemple maîtriser les
ressources permet de préparer
l'appropriation du territoire la
toponymie a aussi son importance
tout au long de l'expédition lewis et
clark grenoble et fleurs les montagnes
et les territoires traversés en hommage
à leur guide à leurs proches ou aux
hommes politiques célèbres de l'époque
cette appropriation par les noms permet
d'inscrire l'amérique dans l'ouest tout
comme les rapports de missions qui sont
publiés par la suite permettent de
rendre l'ouest concret aux yeux des
américains même si l'ouest américain
reste lointain je me limite à ces trois
expéditions parce qu'ils en auraient
énormément d'autres a cité j'aurais pu
parler de celle de google du challenger
de l'astrolabe et je vous invite donc à
vous renseigner dessus parce qu'il ya
plein d'histoires passionnantes à
découvrir à la fin du 19e siècle le
terme de naturalistes tend à disparaître
lorsqu'il est remplacé par les
différentes spécialités la botanique la
zoologie la géologie et c'est la mission
des naturalistes
de dresser un inventaire du monde perd
aussi de son intérêt parce qu'on
considère qu'il est découvert
entièrement ou presque
de nos jours cette idée d'inventaire
connaît un renouveau avec la prise de
conscience qu'une grande partie de la
biodiversité nous reste inconnue
et avec la sixième grande crise
d'extinction que nous traversons et dont
nous sommes en grande partie la cause de
nouvelles expéditions sont organisés
pour récolter des spécimens inconnu
avant qu'il ne disparaisse
les étudiants laboratoires et les faire
entrer dans les collections et des bases
de données internationales
ces nouveaux objets d'études peuvent
également faire avancer la recherche
dans le domaine de la santé par exemple
ou permettre de lutter contre la
disparition de la biodiversité
parmi les expéditions moderne on peut
citer celle du commandant cousteau de
1951 en 1996 qui accueillait de nombreux
scientifiques à bord et ont permis de
développer l'étude de la biodiversité
marine et de compléter les collections
du muséum d'histoire naturelle d'un bon
millier de spécimens de nombreuses
missions françaises sont aussi lancés
vers l'antarctique depuis la découverte
de la terre adélie par dumont d'urville
en 1840 elle échantillonne observe les
espèces et dresse un inventaire détaillé
de la biodiversité tout en étudiant
aussi les perturbations des changements
climatiques sur ces espèces enfin en
2009 a été lancé le programme la planète
revisitée par le muséum d'histoire
naturelle et pro natura international
son objectif est de développer les
connaissances sur les zones les plus
riches en biodiversité et les plus
menacées de la planète depuis son
lancement il a déjà organisé cinq
expéditions
le vanuatu le mozambique et madagascar
la papouasie nouvelle guinée la guyane
et la nouvelle calédonie et continue de
travailler sur de nouvelles destinations
tout comme au xviiie siècle des amateurs
peuvent aussi prendre part aux
inventaires naturalistes via de
nombreuses institutions comme les
conservatoires botaniques l'office
national de la chasse et de la faune
sauvage les parcs nationaux des centres
de recherche des bureaux d'études privés
ou des associations recensées les
papillons dans son jardin où les oiseaux
entendu lors d'une promenade en forêt
pour un amateur entraîné participent à
cet effort d'inventaire toutes
disciplines confondues les sociétés
savantes et associations regroupe 800
mille membres en france dont 10 % active
dans la recherche
ces sociétés et ses associations publie
des bulletins des documents
d'information pour le grand public on
compte par exemple plus de 40
périodiques régionaux sur l'ornithologie
l'apport des amateurs est d'autant plus
précieux qu'ils se consacrent souvent
adepte
même délaissé par la recherche
professionnelle l'étude des escargots
des chauves-souris nous des plantes qui
poussent en ville voilà j'espère que cet
épisode vous a plu et sachez que ceux
qui sortiront à partir de cet été seront
un petit peu différent puisque je
déménage
ceci était donc le dernier tournage dans
cet appartement qui aura connu time warp
chronique de profs et en aventure bref à
bientôt pour un gentes dames badass
partager cet épisode si vous l'avez
apprécié et je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez contribuer au financement de ma
chaîne sur tipi ou your type les liens
sont dans la description
merci beaucoup au revoir en dessous une
mauvaise note à elle est un peu fort
quand notre cher
[Musique]
longtemps par l accord